Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, today we're going to
continue talking about imaging.
Last Tuesday--on Tuesday I
talked mainly about imaging
using X-rays and the
conventional sorts of X-ray
which a chest X-ray which leads
to a projected image.
So, you understand the
limitations of projected images,
and from X-rays something about
the physics of how an X-ray
image is formed based on X-rays
passing through your body.
Depending on what tissues,
what types of tissues the X-ray
passes through,
some of that X-ray energy will
be absorbed.
Therefore, only a fraction of
it is available to pass all the
way through your body and expose
the X-ray film.
We're going to talk about
several alternate forms of
imaging today,
many of which are similar to CT
imaging.
Now, CT imaging is a special
form of X-ray imaging where you
rotate the source of X-rays and
the detector around the object
you're trying to image around
the patient.
You take images at a large
number of angles and using
mathematical approaches you
reconstruct the three
dimensional image from those
multiple two dimensional
projections.
That mathematical process is
called reconstruction from back
projections and it results in a
three dimensional image,
in a CT a slice of the object
of the patient is obtained by
rotating the source in the
detector around that axial
location.
What we're going to start
with is talking about an
alternate to CT--we're going to
talk about an alternate to CT
which forms the same kind of
images.
That is, images of an axial
location, maybe a transverse
image;
a slice from the body will be
imaged using a technique called
magnetic resonance as an
alternative to using X-rays.
We talked last time about one
of the problems with X-rays,
that X-rays had a lot of
beneficial qualities for making
images.
They pass through tissues,
they allow you to look inside,
they're absorbed selectively by
tissues of different density,
they're able to expose X-ray
film, and all of those
properties make them very good
for forming images.
The problem is that
X-rays--X-ray radiation is a
form of ionizing radiation that
can cause damage to cells and
tissues in the body.
One has to be careful about how
much dose you expose a
particular patient to.
In magnetic resonance
imaging, you use magnetic fields
and radio frequency radiation,
non-ionizing forms of radiation
in order to form an image.
The kind of image you form is
the same.
You form a three dimensional
image of objects,
but since the physics is
different,
the things that create contrast
or your ability to see one
object from another in an MR
image are different than in a CT
image.
In a CT image,
what forms the contrast is the
absorbance of X-rays by the
tissue.
So, your lungs,
which are mostly air,
allow X-rays to pass through
relatively easily.
They're different from soft
tissue like blood or the muscle
tissue of your heart which
absorbs some of those X-rays,
and they're different from
bone, which absorb a lot of
those X-rays.
It's density of the tissue,
absorbance of the X-rays that
leads to contrast.
One of the things I didn't
talk about last time was that
sometimes physicians,
when they want to images of
objects where there's not a lot
of intrinsic contrast--like,
say, you want to look at the
intestine, but if you take an
X-ray of the abdomen everything
appears like soft tissue,
everything looks about the same.
If you, however,
fill up the intestines with air
by feeding air to the patient or
by somehow getting air into the
intestinal tract,
then that image will appear
dark where that air is.
You can create contrast,
you can see what's inside of
the intestine that way.
Another way you can do it is by
having the patient drink
something that absorbs X-rays
very readily and that something
is usually a solution of barium,
a colloidal barium solution
that's very X-ray dense.
So, you can create contrast
that way;
a digression,
something I didn't mention last
time and it is mentioned in the
chapter.
What I want to talk about
MR is different way of forming
images, uses a different kind of
physics,
and so the elements of
intrinsic contrast are
different.
We'll talk about what makes MR
images in a few moments.
Bone does not appear well on MR
images, whereas,
bone appeared very well in
X-rays and CT's for example.
If you've taken chemistry,
some chemistry in college or in
high school, you've probably
heard of NMR,
nuclear magnetic resonance.
It was discovered by chemists
as a way of analyzing chemical
samples.
It turns out that if you put
certain nuclei,
if you put certain atoms in a
magnetic field,
some of them will align with
the magnetic field because they
have a magnetic dipole;
atoms have a magnetic dipole.
Hydrogen atoms or protons have
an odd number of nuclei,
of neutrons or protons.
Because of that they have a
dipole, a magnetic dipole.
You put them in a magnetic
field, they will align with that
magnetic field.
If you then perturb the
molecules that are aligned with
the magnetic field using radio
frequency waves or other
magnetic fields,
we'll talk about this in a
moment, then you can measure
something about the properties
of the atom.
Chemists use this,
because it turns out that if
you align all the hydrogen atoms
or protons in a sample,
if you align them in a magnetic
field and then you stimulate
them with the right kind of
radio frequency,
they will respond by producing
a radio frequency of their own,
by producing an energy emission
of their own.
That energy emission is at
radio frequency wavelengths and
you can detect it.
Protons that are in different
environments will respond
slightly differently.
A proton that is--or a
hydrogen--I'm going to say
proton instead of hydrogen atom
because that's easier to say,
or hydrogen ion,
a proton that's in a fatty
solution will behave differently
when stimulated in a magnetic
field than one that's in water.
One that's in bone will behave
even differently than that.
The properties that you can
measure by this process called
nuclear magnetic resonance
depend not only on the atom that
you're stimulating,
hydrogen in this case,
but the microenvironment or
local surrounding that the atom
finds itself in.
If you talked about this in
chemistry, you might talk about
distinguishing different
hydrogen ions that are
associated with an alcohol
molecule or with a benzene ring,
and how ones that are in
different positions on the
molecule will actually respond
differently,
give you what chemists call
different chemical shifts.
It's that same phenomenon
that's being used here to create
images.
It was discovered in 1946 that
atomic nuclei could absorb and
reemit radio frequency energy,
and particularly,
when they were aligned in a
magnetic field.
That led this discovery of the
nuclear magnetic resonance
concept;
led to the Nobel Prize in
Physics in 1952.
It's called nuclear magnetic
resonance because it
involves--it depends on the
particular properties of the
nuclei of atoms,
that is the number or protons,
the number or neutrons.
It's magnetic,
because a magnetic field is
required in order to align the
ions.
It's called resonance because
you're looking for a resonance
between the excitation of these
molecules,
these aligned molecules,
aligned in a magnetic field
which are exciting them with
radio frequency waves.
You're looking for a particular
resonance between the magnetic
field that's applied and the
stimulation that you give with
radio frequency.
Now, when I was introducing
the subject, I didn't call it
nuclear magnetic resonance
imaging, I called it magnetic
resonance imaging or MRI.
That's the common name that's
used for making medical images
using this particular physical
approach.
Why do you think the name was
changed from nuclear magnetic
resonance to MRI during the
1980s when this technique
started to be used in people?
Anything with nuclear doesn't
sound so good.
You don't want anything with
nuclear done to you,
probably because of other uses
of nuclei and concerns about
nuclear sources of energy and
that kind of thing,
so the name was changed.
I don't want you to be confused
because the phenomenon is the
same.
To perform magnetic
resonance and to make magnetic
resonance images you need a very
strong magnetic field.
Magnetic fields,
if you remember from physics,
are measured in a unit called
Tesla.
Most of the clinical units that
are used to perform magnetic
resonance images have magnetic
fields ranging from 1.5 to 4.0
Tesla.
A Tesla, another unit for that
is the Gauss and the conversion
factor shown here.
Just to put it in perspective,
you know that the Earth has a
magnetic field,
that's why compasses work;
has a magnetic field.
If you have a compass which is
just a device that detects the
Earth's magnetic field always
aligns with North,
for example.
The magnetic field of the Earth
is about .3 Gauss or--and it
ranges between .3 and .6 so a
Gauss is a--that would convert
to--.6 Gauss converts to 60
micro-Tesla.
So 60 x 10^(-6) Tesla is the
magnetic field of the Earth,
we're talking about much,
much higher magnetic fields
than that.
You'll need to know this
because you're going to go down
and visit the MR research center
at Yale this afternoon.
Magnetic fields of this
strength can interact with other
magnetic objects like credit
cards that you might have in
your pockets,
or keys that you have in your
pockets.
So when you enter an MR suite,
you have to make sure that
you're not carrying anything
metal,
wearing anything metal,
or carrying anything magnetized
that has a risk of being
demagnetized with it because
these are very strong magnetic
fields.
Because of this the MR facility
that you will see here at Yale
is in the basement of The Anlyan
Center and usually these
machines are in the basement.
If you got to a hospital
and you have an MR taken;
usually you go down to the
basement.
Why is that?
Because they're put in rooms
that are specially shielded,
they're specially shielded so
that the magnetic fields cannot
penetrate outside of the room.
That's so that people that are
walking by on the street don't
have their credit cards erased.
People that are walking by on
the street don't have metal
objects pulled out of their
hands by the strong magnetic
fields.
This is one of the risks for
people that work around nuclear
magnetic resonance imaging,
is that the fields are so
strong that any metal object
that's in the vicinity of the
magnetic can be become a
projectile.
They're very cautious about
metal, another reason why we
asked you not to take any stuff
that's unnecessary with you when
you go down to The Anlyan Center
this afternoon.
The magnetic fields are very
strong.
Anybody had an MR image
taken?
Wilma, several of you;
it was a device,
it might not have looked
exactly like this but looked
something like this.
This looks similar to the CAT
scanner I showed you last time,
in that there is an instrument
with a--basically a big cylinder
with a cylindrical hole in the
middle.
This hole, this is where the
patient is going to go,
the patient will be lying on
this cart,
and this will act like a
conveyor belt that will move the
patient inside the cylinder.
It's close-fitting,
you don't want the size of the
cylinder to be too far away from
the patient because you want the
magnetic field forces and the
radio waves that are emitted by
the ions in your--by the atoms
in your body to be very close to
the detectors that are measuring
it.
Because of this,
when you're inside,
many people--Wilma did you
experience this?
You feel claustrophobic when
you're inside the machine
because you're in a very
confined space and the images
take some time to acquire.
The quality of the image
depends on the strength of the
magnetic field and how long you
acquire the image.
If you have more time to wait
you can get a better image,
and so there's a tradeoff
between building magnets that
are incredibly strong,
which is very expensive and
time for the patient to be
inside the instrument to acquire
an image that has a high
quality.
Surrounding this cylinder
are coils and coils,
many miles of coils of wire,
and electrical field.
Electricity passes through
these wires in order to create a
big electromagnet and large
magnetic fields within this
machine.
Now, the other thing about the
machine is that the operator can
control the strength of the
magnetic fields,
it can control stimulation of
the object with radio frequency
waves, and it can control what
radio frequency signals it picks
up from the object as well.
One of the advantages of MR,
and we'll see a little bit more
about this as we go through the
physics, is that it can be
tuned.
You can tune the imaging method
in order to look at the kinds of
things that you would like to
look at.
That turns out to be one of the
powerful things about MR.
People are still discovering
new ways to look at the
resonance between the magnetic
field and its affect on atoms
and the radio frequencies that
are generated,
to learn how make new kinds of
images.
We'll talk about some of that
as we go.
The magnetic resonance
that's most done in people for
clinical imaging takes advantage
of the fact that our bodies are
largely water.
All those water molecules have
hydrogen atoms associated with
them.
There's a lot of hydrogen in
your body, and hydrogen atoms
are susceptible to magnetic
resonance because they contain
this dipole moment that will
align in a magnetic field.
What happens in magnetic
resonance is you're placed in a
very large magnetic field.
Many of the hydrogen nuclei
in the molecules within your
body align with this magnetic
field,
and then the machine sort of
tips those aligned molecules out
of alignment.
If that's done properly,
you will start a kind of motion
in these molecules,
what's called a procession,
where the molecules move like a
top.
When they are performing this
kind of motion within the
magnetic field,
they're trying to get back to
the preferred alignment but
they're doing that in this
top-like fashion.
If you have many,
many atoms that are all
processing in the right way they
will emit radio frequency waves
that you can detect in this
cylinder outside.
This shows it sort of
schematically.
You have atoms inside your
body, these are hydrogen atoms,
for example.
You place the body within a
strong magnetic field,
and these atoms align so that
they are parallel with the
magnetic field,
which is going from top to
bottom here.
You stimulate these atoms with
radio frequency waves and you
knock them out of alignment.
Now, you can't just stimulate
them with any radio frequency
wave, that radio frequency wave
has to be exactly right for the
atoms that you want to move.
It has to be radio waves that
are at the correct frequency or
wavelength to stimulate these
particular atoms.
That's one of the things that
makes MR so versatile,
in that if you stimulate them
with one frequency,
you can manipulate hydrogen
atoms.
If you stimulate them with
another frequency,
you can stimulate other atoms.
Now, the reason why most of
the images you'll see are based
on protons or hydrogen nuclei is
because hydrogen is so much more
abundant than everything else in
your body,
and so you get a good signal
with that.
If you were stimulating other
kinds of atoms,
you wouldn't get as strong a
signal, you wouldn't be able to
make as good an image.
You stimulate these atoms with
a radio frequency,
they begin this motion or this
procession,
and this just shows
schematically that this
procession is like a top.
They're out of alignment,
the nuclei are rotating.
They're eventually coming back
to their equilibrium position
which would be aligned with the
magnet again.
What you measure in the MR
device is this relaxation from
the excited or tipped position,
relaxing back to their
equilibrium or aligned position.
Now, if you go on--if any
of you go on to study quantum
mechanics or you try to study
the physics of medical imaging,
particularly MR in more detail,
you'll learn that this simple
description I gave you is not
entirely accurate.
It's not inaccurate,
but it doesn't describe the
whole thing.
It's really a quantum mechanics
phenomenon that's happening with
the molecules here.
It can't be described
completely unless you have the
sort of tools of quantum physics
to describe it,
but this is a sufficient way of
thinking about what's going on
in here.
What you measure,
then, is the relaxation of
these excited molecules back to
their aligned state.
You can measure that because as
these molecules are processing
they're emitting radio frequency
radiation which you can detect.
Now, this involves magnetic
fields, strong magnetic fields.
It involves radio frequency
radiation, the kind of radiation
that radio stations use to
broadcast signals that are
picked up by antennas.
These are generally presumed to
be safe for biological tissues.
There's no ill effects that we
know of, of exposure to magnetic
fields or radio frequency
radiation at these wavelengths.
So, it doesn't have the same
concerns that X-ray radiation or
other kinds of radiation,
which I'll talk about in a few
minutes, have.
This is some examples of MR
images.
These are MR images that are
taken at different locations in
the brain.
Remember, now,
that the patient is being
conveyed on this table into the
core of the instrument and
measurements are made only on
the part of the body that's
inside the instrument.
Just like in CT image,
you move the patient through
and you take images of different
slices through the patient.
Now, if the patient is having a
brain or head MR scan,
you would just put them in
until you went through this part
of the body.
If you're doing it in the
abdomen or the leg,
you would just scan that part
of the body.
This shows, then,
images, transverse images at
various locations moving down.
This is near the top of the
head, this a little further
down, you can see the
ventricles.
I think actually these two
images might be from the same
location, but they show you one
of the features of MR.
That is, by looking at
different relaxations or
stimulating with different
pulses of radio frequency,
you can see different kinds of
contrast.
In this image you can see more
clearly the distinction between
gray matter and white matter.
In this image you don't see
that so clearly but you see
better the distinction between
brain tissue and the cerebral
spinal fluid that's in the
ventricles.
The point is that the technique
can be tuned to see what you
would like to see best.
Then, going farther down in the
brain you see--now you're seeing
some of the bones of the face
and the cerebellum back here,
or a lower section of the brain.
So, this is a section probably
from somewhere in here and this
is even lower down than that.
These are just examples of some
magnetic resonance images.
As I mentioned,
magnetic resonance is not so
good at looking at bone because
bone doesn't have a lot of water
in it.
Doesn't have a lot of--so it
doesn't contribute a lot of
signal but it's very good for
looking at differences between
soft tissues.
Remember in CT soft tissues
like the muscular wall of the
heart and the blood that's
inside the heart look roughly
the same.
You can't distinguish those
well, there's not intrinsic
contrast.
With MR there is intrinsic
contrast because those--the
properties of those different
tissues are different by this
method.
A newer form of magnetic
resonance imaging is called
functional MR imaging and it
uses the same machine.
It uses the same approach,
but instead of designing your
radio frequency pulses so that
you look at the static
structure,
you design it so that you're
particularly sensitive for
looking at flowing blood.
You can actually measure the
velocity of blood flow in
different regions of the brain.
Now, you can do that because
blood contains a lot of water.
This is water that's not
static, just staying in one
place in the brain,
but it's moving through blood
vessels.
You can detect the motion of
the blood vessels with this
technique.
It can also tell the
difference between saturated and
desaturated blood.
What's saturated blood?
Here, I mean blood that's
saturated with oxygen,
so it's loaded up with oxygen;
desaturated blood is blood
that's had the oxygen removed.
Now, if you can measure blood
flow and you can measure
differences between saturated
and desaturated blood,
that means that you can monitor
within a small region of tissue
how much blood flow is going
through,
how much oxygen is being
consumed.
You can measure,
locally, what's the rate of
oxygen consumption in a tissue.
Now, if you know oxygen
consumption, then you know
something about metabolic
activity in that tissue.
A region of tissue that's
consuming a lot of oxygen is
doing a lot of work.
In the brain,
if you find regions of tissue
that are consuming oxygen,
that means those are regions of
tissue where there's a lot of
energy being consumed,
those are regions of tissue
where there's a lot of neural
activity, a lot of brain cells
doing what brain cells do.
It's called functional MR
imaging because through this
approach, one can look inside
the brain,
for example,
and find regions that are
performing functions.
An experiment that--well,
the other thing about fMRI
before I talk about the
experiment,
is that instead of just looking
at anatomy now,
this is a high resolution
picture of the anatomy of the
brain,
an fMRI image is fuzzier.
You don't have as high a
resolution and that's because
you want to take images fast,
you don't want to wait a long
time.
You want to be--you want to see
how the image changes with time.
In a static image,
when they took a picture of
Wilma for example,
they kept her inside the
machine for a while so that they
could get a really high
resolution image of the
structure in her brain.
She was asked to remain very
still because you don't want to
have any motion,
you want just a picture of the
static's.
In fMRI, you want to take a
picture faster but then you want
to look at how it changes with
time because it's these changes
in time that allow you to look
at things like oxygen
consumption.
You have to look over time in
order to measure that.
In an fMRI--in one kind of
fMRI imaging you look at blood
oxygen level,
that's a measure of neural
activity,
when blood oxygen goes up
neural activity goes up,
the extraction of oxygen goes
up and the fMRI signal goes up.
Here's an example of an fMRI
image, and actually the fMRI
image isn't shown here.
The fMRI image would be a
blurry one like the one I showed
you in the last slide.
You might find regions where
there's high levels of activity,
and you would superimpose those
on a static image of that same
brain,
so here two kinds of imaging
were done.
One was the high resolution MR
imaging to get a picture of the
anatomy, and then this more
rapid time sequence of images to
find out where oxygen
consumption was occurring.
What was discovered was
that oxygen consumption is
occurring in this location here
and this location here.
This is known to be a certain
area of the brain called Broca's
area that's involved in speech.
I don't remember whether it's
in hearing and decoding speech
or in producing speech,
I think it's in hearing and
decoding speech but I don't
remember.
In this particular example
mixed speech was--while the
patient was being imaged they
were being exposed to speech
that included a mixture of
languages,
both Spanish and English.
In this picture they were only
listening to Spanish,
in this picture they were only
listening to English.
What you see is that when the
mixed--under the mixed
condition, when they're hearing
both Spanish and English,
there's a certain portion of
the brain that's more active
than it is with only Spanish and
only English.
From this you can conclude that
this part of the brain must be
involved, somehow,
in the special activity that
was happening at this point
here.
That is some kind of mixed
language experience.
Many, many--this as you
could extrapolate from this,
and you could imagine that this
approach where you could look at
what areas of the brain become
active during sorts of
activities,
certain sorts of behavior,
when certain emotions are
elicited, has become a very
powerful tool in psychology.
You can do psychological
experiments while patients are
getting fMRI scans,
and you can find out what parts
of the brain are involved in
that kind of psychological
response.
This imaging is teaching us a
lot more than just what is the
normal structure of tissue,
in this case the brain looks
like, but how does it really
work in a functioning animal
like a person.
That's a very brief
introduction to MR imaging,
there's a lot more to learn
about this,
you'll learn more about this,
and you'll see some of these
instruments this afternoon.
There's more detail in the book
as well.
A second kind of imaging which
shares an advantage with MR in
that it does not involve
ionizing radiation is ultrasound
imaging.
Ultrasound imaging is different
from the others we've talked
about in that there is no
electromagnetic radiation
involved.
You're not using light or
different forms of light;
you're using sound to create
images instead.
Sounds is pressure waves that
transmit through a medium.
When I'm talking up here my
vocal apparatus is creating
waves of pressure in the air
which get transmitted through
the room.
You can understand them because
the waves of pressure that I'm
creating stimulate your eardrums
at the right frequencies and you
convert that into sound.
Ultrasound uses much,
much higher frequencies of
sound than our ears can detect.
We detect, I forget exactly
what the range is,
but up to I think 40,000 Hz or
cycles per second is the
frequency and this is in the
megaHertz range or millions of
Hertz range,
so it's higher frequency sounds
than you can hear.
Some have very short--of these
high frequency sound waves have
very short wavelengths.
They can penetrate through
tissues.
Ultrasound allows for good
imaging of anatomical structure.
It's also a fast imaging
method, and so it can allow you
to look at motion in ways that
are difficult to do using some
of these other techniques,
and I'll tell you about that.
The way that ultrasound
works is you have to get sound
waves propagated into the body
and you do that through a
special device called an
ultrasound transducer.
The transducer is placed right
on the surface of your body.
It might look like a cylinder
like a probe that's placed
against the surface of your
body.
Usually not even just placed
against a surface of your body,
but it's placed with some kind
of a gel,
a liquid gel such that the
probe comes in very good contact
with your skin.
That's because sound waves
don't transmit very easily
across interfaces.
If I put something up between
my voice and you,
then the sound waves don't
transmit as well,
you can't hear it.
Sound waves bounce off
interfaces.
You want to get the sound to go
into the skin,
you have to put the transducer,
which is producing the sound
waves, right up against the
skin.
You don't want a gap of air in
between and that's why you put
the gel.
Now, this transducer has a
special material in it that's
called a piezoelectric material.
Piezoelectric materials have
the property that if you put a
voltage through them they
resonate, or they physically
move.
In addition,
if you stimulate a
piezoelectric material with a
moving wave, it will create a
voltage.
Voltages get transmitted into
movements.
In this transducer the movement
gets transmitted into sound
wave--is what produces the sound
waves that get transmitted into
your skin and through your body.
Because these piezoelectric
materials can both form sound
when they're stimulated and they
can detect sound and convert it
into electricity when they're
stimulated by sound,
then the transducer is both
sending out sound waves and
receiving sound waves back.
These work basically by the
same principle that an echo
works.
If I shout in the right kind of
a room where there's nothing to
absorb the sound between me and
the back wall,
the sound will hit the back
wall and it will be reflected
back to me.
I will hear that sound some
time interval later.
You've all had the experience
of hearing an echo.
The same thing happens here,
you transmit sound into the
skin and it moves forward until
it hits an interface.
Sound doesn't move so well
across interfaces,
so it moves through your skin
and it goes down and hits the
bone.
There's an interface between
materials here that have two
different properties:
skin, muscle,
bone.
At each one of those interfaces
some of the sound bounces back.
Since the detector is both
sending sound and receiving
sound, it sends out a sound wave
and then it gets the sound back.
It can determine how long it
took for the sound to come back.
If I know the speed of sound
and I know how long it took for
an echo to return,
I can calculate how far away
the object was that created the
echo or the interference.
Ultrasound works by sending out
sound waves that bounce back,
are received,
and the machine calculates how
long it took for this echo to go
out and come back.
Then, it knows there must have
been some kind of an object at
that distance away.
Does that make sense?
Ultrasound creates echo time
maps and calculates depths from
that.
Here's an ultrasound image
of the heart and it's the heart
turned upside down.
This vaguely familiar to you
from a few weeks ago,
but the atria are on the top
and the--or the atria are on the
bottom and the ventricles are on
the top.
That's just to show you in
alignment with this image here.
The probe is placed on the
chest, for example,
and it's moved from side to
side at one location.
So, what you see is an image of
what the probe can see as it
sort of sweeps out this cone
where the sound is moving.
What you see is that there are
boundaries between light and
dark regions here,
and those correspond to
boundaries in the tissue.
You can see the right atrium,
you can see the right ventricle
over here.
You can see the left atrium and
the left ventricle because the
white region is the muscular
tissue of the heart,
and the darker region is the
blood that's within the heart.
Now, you'll notice that
it's kind of a--it's not a sharp
image like the images that I
showed you with CT,
or the images that I showed you
with MR.
It's a noisier image and there
are--there's a lot of sort of
white spots or dark spots
throughout it.
Those are things that are
called speckles,
it's talked about in your book.
There are random sources of
interference with the ultrasound
image.
The reason why ultrasound is
useful is because you can watch
things with time,
and so you can see motion.
In static pictures it looks
like a very noisy image,
but if you were watching this
in real time you would see the
motion of the heart.
The speckles wouldn't be as
obvious because you'd be
noticing more how the walls of
the ventricle move,
for example,
in time.
That would be very clear from
the image.
What would also be clear to
you is the motion of the valves,
and we talked about the very
critical role that valves play
in the function of your heart.
If your valves aren't working
right you can't make an
efficient heartbeat,
that is, a heartbeat that
produces a cardiac output.
Ultrasound imaging has been one
of the most used tools for
looking at valve disease,
and that event is called
echocardiography.
Have you ever heard of that
term echocardiography?
Which is basically ultrasound
of the heart and it's used
principally to look at the
function of your valve,
the mitral valve and the
tricuspid valve,
here.
If this was a video image you
would see the valves opening and
closing in correct coordination
hopefully with the contraction
of the heart.
Ultrasound allows you to look
at motion, and so to see things
that are moving that would be
difficult to do with other
techniques.
You also know,
and probably all of you in this
room have--pictures were taken
of you when you were in
utero. Ultrasound imaging is
a very common form of fetal
monitoring now,
where almost every woman who is
pregnant has at least one
ultrasound image taken at some
course during the pregnancy just
to make sure that the pregnancy
is proceeding properly.
This is an example of an
ultrasound image,
it looks the same way,
an ultrasound image of an
infant.
This is the kind of ultrasound
imaging machine that you might
find in an obstetrics office.
You can see,
in this particular case,
that here's the head of the
fetus, here's an arm,
here's the torso.
Again, it's not a very sharp
image, but if you were watching
this in real time as the
technician moved the probe
around on the pregnant woman's
abdomen,
you would see the baby moving.
You would be able to
distinguish parts much more
easily in that way because
you're moving both the probe and
the baby's moving,
and you're seeing things from
different angles in real time as
it's happening.
This is a very common technique.
I wouldn't be surprised if many
of you, if you don't have a
picture of yourself in
utero in your scrapbook,
probably your mother has one
somewhere, all infants of your
age were ultrasound.
Ultrasound is also a good
technique for looking at flow.
When you look at flow you're
taking advantage of something
called the Doppler effect.
In physics you've probably
heard about the Doppler effect.
A simple way of thinking about
it is if you're standing on the
street and there's an ambulance
coming towards you or a car
that's coming towards you and
the horn is honking.
As the car is approaching you,
you hear a certain frequency of
sound that changes as the car
passes.
The frequency of the sound that
you hear depends both on the
frequency of the sound that's
being emitted by the siren and
the speed that the ambulance is
moving relative to you.
When the ambulance is moving
towards you, you hear a
frequency that's offset from the
real frequency of the siren.
When it's moving away from you
its offset even more and you can
hear that.
If I'm doing ultrasound
imaging, imaging with sound
waves, of an object that's
moving away from the probe,
I can detect both where it is
and how fast it's moving by the
frequency of the signal that's
returned to the probe.
That allows you to image the
rate of blood flow through
vessels, and that's shown in
this picture here.
You can measure the rate of
blood flow through the carotid
arteries, for example.
That turns out to be a very
useful technique for patients
that have cerebral vascular
disease.
They're getting arthrosclerosis
or hardening of the arteries in
the important vessels going up
to their neck that can be
measured--through their neck up
to their brain that can be
measured using ultrasound.
Those two methods--magnetic
resonance ultrasound having the
big advantage,
that they don't involve
ionizing radiation.
Magnetic resonance imaging in
general takes a long time,
requires very expensive
equipment.
Ultrasound imaging can be done
in real time.
You can take pictures,
images of the inside rapidly.
The equipment is not so
expensive, so any doctor's
office can have an ultrasound
machine.
The image quality is not as
high, but you can image things
that are in motion.
These imaging approaches are
used for different applications
because of the advantages that
each one has.
I want to talk briefly
about nuclear medicine.
I'm going to have to go fast
here.
This does use a form of
ionizing radiation,
in particular,
gamma rays.
Gamma rays are produced by
nuclear events,
events inside the nucleus;
in particular,
they happen when radioactive
isotopes decay.
When radioactive isotopes like
Zenon-133, Technetium-99,
Iodine-123, these are unstable
isotopes of these molecules.
So, with a certain frequency,
they will decay back to their
more stable form.
When they decay,
they emit a form of radiation
called gamma radiation,
many of these.
Gamma rays--remember on the
electromagnetic spectrum,
they were up there with X-rays,
high frequency,
short wavelength radiation,
penetrates easily through
tissue but is also an example of
ionizing radiation.
Now, the difference between
nuclear medicine and--what's
called nuclear medicine and
conventional X-rays is in
X-rays,
the X-ray source was outside of
you and you were being bombarded
with X-rays.
In nuclear medicine,
the gamma ray source is
injected inside of you.
What you measure is the amount
of radiation that comes out.
Now, what's the advantage of
that?
Well, the advantage is if I can
find radioisotopes that
concentrate in certain regions
of your body and I inject those
isotopes into you,
and then measure where they
are, I can measure the function
of that particular region of
your body.
The first imaging that was
done was done in the thyroid and
your thyroid has a very active
mechanism for concentrating
iodine.
Because of that if I feed
somebody radioactive iodine that
iodine will accumulate in their
thyroid gland which is in your
neck.
The rate at which it
accumulates and the pattern at
which it accumulates can
indicate whether you have a
healthy or a diseased thyroid.
If I, then, take images of the
thyroid after I've injected the
radioactivity and I look to see
if the radioactivity is there,
and how fast it gets there,
and how fast your body removes
it, then I can learn something
about how your thyroid is
functioning because of its
ability to concentrate iodine.
That's one example of it.
Imagine you have a chemical
that accumulates in the brain
and accumulates only in certain
areas.
For example,
you have a chemical that's
related to the neurotransmitter
dopamine and you give it to a
patient that you suspect of
having Parkinson's Disease.
Well, Parkinson's Disease
involves the brain neurons that
process and use dopamine and so
if this radio chemical goes up
into the brain it's going to
interact with those cells that
are involved in Parkinson's
Disease.
By watching how this molecule
moves around in the brain I can
learn about how your brain is
processing dopamine and if it's
responding in a normal sort of
way.
Does that make sense?
The advantage of nuclear
medicine is that you're
designing very specific kinds of
radioactive molecules that you
can put into the body.
The molecules are designed to
illuminate some kind of
biological function,
not structure.
Then, I measure the time course
of how those objects--how those
radio labeled compounds move
through your body.
There are several ways of
measuring it.
I'm just going to show you the
simple one here;
not simple one but a very
powerful one called Positron
Emission Tomography.
Here the chemical that's
emitted is a special radio
isotope that emits not gamma
rays but another
nuclear--another particle called
a positron.
When positrons are emitted,
they will move through tissue
until they hit an electron.
Positrons don't have to move
very far, there's lots of
electrons around in tissues.
When a positron hits an
electron, they annihilate one
another and they generate two
gamma rays which move in
opposite directions.
If I have a positron emitting
substance in the brain,
it will emit gamma rays which
can be detected.
Because I'm detecting one here
and one here,
I know exactly where the source
came from.
I can trace it back along the
lines where I detected the gamma
rays and I can find out where
the positron emitting element
was.
So, I can make very nice maps
of the brain like these that
show you where the positron
emitting isotope accumulates in
the brain.
This is called PET imaging.
I'm going to skip over this
one which tells you a little bit
about the economics of these
different modalities.
Ultrasound, as I mentioned,
was cheaper;
CT costs more,
MR in general cost more,
PET imaging costs even more
because you have to generate
radio isotopes locally at the
source too.
In general you need a cyclotron
or some kind of a machine to
generate these radio isotopes as
well.
There are other things you have
to think about if you're
thinking about installing these,
is how much do they cost to
operate and how heavily do
technicians have to be involved
in order to keep them working.
The last thing I want to
talk about is optical imaging,
and as I mentioned last time,
I think that during your
lifetime we're going to see a
lot of new approaches for using
light to image inside the body.
That's a problem because light
doesn't penetrate through your
body, it bounces off;
most of it bounces off.
That's why we can see each
other, because we're seeing the
reflected light off of different
objects.
You can use light to look at
biological objects.
You can look at them in great
detail this way and that's what
microscopes do.
They allow you to use light
radiation in order to look at
magnified images of biological
objects.
We've gotten very good at
designing microscopes that allow
us to look at,
in very sophisticated ways,
at biological objects on the
stage of a microscope.
This just shows you an
image, it's actually very
similar to the CT scans or MR
scans I showed you before,
in that these are different
optical sections taken from a
pollen grain.
A pollen grain is very small.
Here's an image from the bottom
moving up, moving up,
moving up--this shows you all
the three dimensional detail of
this particular pollen grain.
You can reconstruct in three
dimensions and see what it looks
on the outside,
or you could look and see what
it's like at any point in its
interior structure.
We're very sophisticated at
using light to make images like
this now on microscope stages.
One could take very beautiful
pictures of biological objects
like cells with different kinds
of optical techniques.
Here's--this is familiar to
you, this is a glomerulus.
I told you what a glomerulus
was last week,
but this shows sort of the tuft
of capillaries inside a
glomerulus imaged by light
microscopy.
Well, how do I take advantage
of this kind of microscopy but
look at these kinds of images
inside people?
We don't how to do that yet,
but we do have some
technologies for looking
at--using light to look inside
and the main one is called
endoscopy.
Endoscopy involves objects
called fiber optics,
and fiber optics allow you to
not only focus light through a
lens but to take that light and
bounce it down an optical shaft.
I could take a light beam and
shine it here into a fiber.
That fiber has a special
coating on which then allows the
light to bounce all the way down
the fiber.
I can bend the fiber,
and because the bouncing
depends on the coating and not
the shape of the fiber,
the light will turn with the
fiber.
This is how fiber optics works;
it's described a little bit
more in detail in your book.
One can design devices like
this endoscope.
This endoscope you can look
through this end here,
it has a light source.
That light source shines
through fiber optics that you
can bend around,
and that light comes out the
outside.
If the light comes out the
outside it hits some biological
object and then bounces back
light, reflects light and you
can see it.
You can look inside objects
where you can put this
endoscope.
This endoscope is designed to
go--a patient will swallow it.
This end will go down in their
mouth, past their vocal chords,
through their esophagus,
into the stomach,
and then out of the stomach
into the duodenum or the first
part of the small intestine.
That's what's shown here.
This is the valve that's
leading from stomach into the
duodenum or the first part of
the small intestine.
You can see what the lining of
the small intestine and the
stomach looks like.
This has been a very important
diagnostic approach for using
light to image the lining of the
stomach.
What would you be looking for?
Things like ulcers,
things like cancers,
any kind of disturbance in the
normal anatomy of the lining of
the gut.
I think you're going to see a
lot of new methods beyond this
for using light to look inside
people as well.
I'll stop there.
Thanks.